you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
cool puzzle that I wanted to share with
you those of you that have been
connected with this channel for some
time now may recall it it's white to
move if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
this one is certainly very unique the
first thing to recognize is that trying
to run the pond up like so is simply not
going to work in fact black will promote
first and be the one who wins so we need
to try something different and the
important thing to realize is that we
cannot win on the white side and so the
best-case scenario is a draw how do we
achieve a draw on position well it comes
in the form of Bishop d2 g2 Bishop a5 do
you see where we're going after g1 Queen
b4 White has officially put themselves
in to self stalemate there are now no
legal moves
pick your favorite place to go with the
Queen this is stalemate a self stalemate
very unique puzzle and hope you enjoyed
it take care bye
you